quelques propos d'introduction rapide
sur cette mission d'information qui a
été proposée par le groupe socialiste
écologique la République
dont je suis membre donc en tant que
rapporteur j'excuse notre président donc
Rémi Cointreau membre du groupe des
Républicains qui n'a pas pu te la
aujourd'hui à côté de cela ce sont des
missions d'information transpartisanes
dans leur composition bien sûr sachant
qu'au niveau du Sénat on cherche
toujours quand même des démarches qui
soient les plus consensuelles aussi
possibles même s'il peut y avoir des
sujets parfois un peu plus clivant et
donc nous devrions rendre nos travaux
fin juin
voilà en termes de calendrier et bien
sûr les éléments que nous n'aurions pas
pu aborder dans le cadre de l'échange
comme vous en avez aussi l'habitude mais
vous pouvez en être assuré vous nous les
transmettez on les prendra aussi en
considération puisque le temps nous est
malheureusement un peu compter ce que je
vous propose dans un premier temps c'est
de pouvoir vous présenter et de
présenter la F p2e peut-être en quelques
mots et puis on va rentrer dans le vif
du questionnaire qu'on vous a transmis
pour pouvoir vous entendre je vous en
prie
merci alors je suis Aurélie Colas je
suis déléguée générale de l'AFP de e
depuis tout juste de moi
bonjour donc Christophe Tanguy je suis
membre du bureau de la FP2E et je suis
le directeur général adjoint du groupe
sort en charge des projets et
initiatives et stratégiques du groupe
bonjour Vincent d'Arras je suis membre
du bureau de l'afp2e et je suis
Directeur Exploitation France de la
Société des autres fins d'Oise groupe
Aqualia
très bien alors peut-être en quelques
mots je vais vous présenter l'afp2e très
très rapidement donc la Fédération des
Entreprises de l'eau regroupe les
entreprises qui assurent les services
publics d'eau et d'assainissement en
France après mise en concurrence les
entreprises de loi alimentent 60% de la
population française en autre côté et un
Français sur deux pour les services
d'assainissement ces adhérents emploi 28
000 personnes en France et comme vous le
savez ils sont répartis sur tout le
territoire national et mène plus
particulièrement des projets de
recherche développement afin de répondre
aux besoins spécifiques des
collectivités l'afp2e a pour raison
d'être devrait à la préservation des
ressources à la qualité de l'eau à
l'avenir de la biodiversité et soutient
la performance des services publics
d'audacement et bien sûr elle interagit
avec l'ensemble de ces parties prenantes
et naturellement cette audition
s'inscrit pleinement dans le cadre de sa
raison d'être
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à un
contexte d'urgence hydrique sans
précédent et dans ce contexte nous
remercions le Sénat d'auditionner la
Fédération des Entreprises de l'eau dans
le cas de cette mission d'information et
nous vous remercions nous permettent de
nous exprimer sur notre vision de la
gestion durable de l'eau puisque s'il
est une ressource qui impacte à la fois
la santé humaine la biodiversité
l'activité économique aujourd'hui et
pour les générations futures dans un
contexte de dérèglement climatique c'est
bien cette ressource
très bien je remercie donc nous sommes
un peu plus de la moitié de la mission
bien sûr il y a certains sujets qui ont
déjà été un peu approfondies avec
Antoine de fond bien sûr les annonces
gouvernementales au niveau du plan haut
et puis un certain nombre de travaux
auxquels vous avez bien sûr participer
peut-être pour aller rapidement donc à
l'essentiel aujourd'hui compte tenu de
ces annonces le plan eau globalement je
pense a été assez bien perçu de votre
part quelles sont les interrogations que
vous pouvez avoir justement par rapport
à par rapport à ces annonces les
inquiétudes éventuelles que vous
souhaiteriez nous communiquer on voit au
niveau de des différentes auditions que
malheureusement la montée en puissance
de la possibilité de l'eau avec les
pollutions diffusent est un aujourd'hui
un sujet qui est de plus en plus majeur
sur la réalisation des eaux usées mais
aussi on sait que c'est pas une solution
majeure c'est une voilà et miracle mais
c'est une voix qui est intéressante à
creuser mais à chaque fois que l'on
aborde cette voie
on a toujours l'impression de se
retrouver devant un mur c'est à dire que
on a du mal à voir comment ce sujet se
crante pour arriver à factuellement
ouvrir des voix qui sont aujourd'hui
fermées aujourd'hui donc peut-être que
vous avez des éléments par rapport à ça
et puis bien sûr il y a en termes de
sobriété aujourd'hui de consommation des
eaux toutes les parties prenantes sont
directement interpellées aujourd'hui sur
ces sujets et nous aimerions avoir
également un retour de votre part donc
premier élément je vous laisse tout de
suite la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur rapporteur mais
mesdames c'est l'actrice sénateur merci
beaucoup pour votre accueil peut-être
repartir d'un constat qui est un constat
qui est partagé par je pense l'ensemble
des experts que vous avez rencontrés que
qu'on analyse aussi avec nos propres
outils d'analyse c'est évidemment le
l'état de la ressource qui est
aujourd'hui extrêmement préoccupant vous
avez bien sûr eu les échos du comité
d'anticipation et de suivi de logique a
eu lieu la semaine dernière avec un
panorama qui est très préoccupant pour
l'été prochain puisque l'on sait que on
n'a pas eu d'hivernale les nappes ne se
sont pas rechargés même s'il y a eu des
épisodes de pluviométrie au mois de mars
et d'avril il y a toujours de très très
fortes tensions sur un arc qui se situe
globalement du du Pays Basque à la
frontière italienne
nous voudrions rappeler aussi que c'est
un phénomène qui n'est pas conjoncturel
et qui n'est certainement pas
conjoncturel et les structurel il est
appelé à durée il est pérenne il est lié
au réchauffement climatique et il a un
impact direct sur l'ensemble du cycle de
l'eau c'est à dire sur les étiages sur
les niveaux des nappes phréatiques sur
la mutation des sols et sur la mutation
des
je rappelle les données que vous
connaissez à l'horizon 2050 10 à 25% de
baisse des niveaux de recharge des
nappes phréatiques annoncées par les
expats de GIEC et 20 à 40% de réduction
du début moyen des fleuves ce qui a
changé peut-être à la faveur de l'été
2022 et c'est un point important pour
pour couvrir l'ensemble des questions de
qui sont abordées par votre mission
c'est la question de la prise de
conscience par nos concitoyens et donc
du degré d'acceptabilité ensuite de
mesurer éventuelles qui pourraient
concourir à la sobriété et puis de
mesures de solutions techniques et
innovantes pour lesquelles il faudrait
investir on sait que désormais selon les
chiffres du centre d'information sur
l'eau on a cette Français sur dix qui
considèrent qu'ils vont manquer d'eau à
l'avenir dans leur région ils étaient
25% il y a à peine 20 ans donc on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une prise de
conscience qui a prise de conscience des
Français que cet enjeu il est
aujourd'hui majeur et qu'il faut y
apporter évidemment des solutions
face à ce constat le plan O est donc été
annoncé vous avez raison monsieur le
rapporteur nous avons largement
participé aux travaux préparatoires à la
fois dans le cas des cinq groupes de
travail qui ont lieu dans le cas du
chantier de la planification écologique
sur l'eau mais également et je voudrais
insister là-dessus à l'étape des assises
de l'eau et à l'étape du varen agricole
de l'eau parce que finalement un certain
nombre de constats étaient posés y
compris sur l'agriculture des solutions
partagées avaient été
identifiées et simplement la mise en
action la mise en oeuvre a fortement
tardé ce que l'on constate avec le plan
o qui a finalement été annoncé après
plusieurs reports c'est que au moins ce
sujet aujourd'hui il est pris au plus
haut sommet l'État par le Président de
la République et par ailleurs il est mis
à l'agenda politique donc nous nous en
réjouissons évidemment parce que nous
considérons je pense que c'est un avis
qui est largement partagé que l'enjeu
est un enjeu majeur et nécessité une
prise en compte politique au plus haut
niveau et une ambition forte
pour pour évoque répondre à votre
interrogation ce que nous on en attend
de ce plan haut c'est deux choses d'une
part une mise en oeuvre complète parce
qu'il est assez complet ce plan il est
très transversal il aborde l'ensemble
des aspects autour de la ressource on
voudrait être certain qu'il va être
entièrement mise en oeuvre et par
ailleurs voudrait être certain qu'il va
être mis en oeuvre rapidement c'est à
dire que face à l'urgence l'urgence
écologique pas seulement l'urgence de la
sécheresse de l'été 2023 il faut que la
mesure soit mise en oeuvre très
rapidement nous avons des points de
vigilance c'était le sens de votre
commission par rapport à l'urgence
de l'exercice
effectivement un plan qui est un plan
pluriel donc qui vise des actions qui
d'ailleurs sont déployées puisqu'il y a
à chaque pour chaque mesure du plan où
il y a une indication de temporalité de
déploiement c'est effectivement un plan
qui s'inscrit de manière plus réelle qui
n'apporte pas tes réponses totalement
immédiates à l'enjeu de la probable
sécheresse de l'été de l'été 2023 de ce
point de vue là et on va y revenir c'est
d'abord et en tous les objectifs de
sobriété et qui peuvent qui peuvent
permettre d'accompagner peut-être une
séquence estivale qui ne soit pas trop
tendue par rapport
crise absolument mais nos entreprises
l'ont vécu l'été dernier et son
mobilisés en prévision de l'été prochain
puis évidemment rien n'est garanti à
date alors les points de vigilance que
nous avons identifié par rapport au plan
o
vous le savez sans doute la filière
française de l'eau évaluée à peu près 3
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
pendant 5 ans le volume budgétaire
nécessaire en termes d'investissement
pour adapter les services publics de
l'eau de l'assainissement au changement
climatique c'est à dire aujourd'hui on
est à peu près à 6 milliards par an on
estime qu'il faut 3 milliards
supplémentaires pendant 5 ans donc 15
milliards sur 50 pour adapter les
services publics d'audacement au
changement climatique donc qu'est-ce que
ça recouvre ça recouvre le
renouvellement des réseaux la mise aux
normes des stations d'épuration la mise
en place d'interconnexion la lutte
contre les micropolluants etc et donc
c'est à la fois des financements de
l'État et des collectivités de ce point
de vue là nous saluons le fait que le
plan o intègre l'annonce de moyens
supplémentaires à louer aux agences de
l'eau c'est-à-dire une hausse de 20%
tout à fait j'y viens nous avons
néanmoins une vraie interrogation sur le
coefficient multiplicateur qui a été
annoncé par le président de la
République puisque il y a un effet
tremplin annoncé de 475 millions d'euros
qui doit être générer 6 milliards
d'euros d'investissement il y a en
commission du développement durable à
l'Assemblée nationale le ministre de la
transition écologique a expliqué qu'il y
avait un rapport de 1 à 10 pour générer
cet effet levier c'est un point
d'interrogation pour nous compte tenu
l'expérience que l'on peut avoir des
investissements qui sont déployés à date
cette capacité d'investissement ce
serait très bien mais cette capacité
d'investissement à hauteur de 6
milliards supplémentaires par an nous
interroge c'est le premier point par
ailleurs nous sommes en attente d'une
intensification des subventions va les
services publics de l'eau
l'assainissement pour soutenir les
innovations qui seraient utiles à la
sobriété et recyclage que soit sur la
réutilisation des eaux usées traités ou
sur la digitalisation des services ce
quand on regarde la ventilation des 475
millions d'euros on se dit que peut-être
qu'on pourrait faire un petit peu plus
je crois que ce que l'on peut dire de
manière générale ce qu'on peut retenir
c'est que les sommes qui sont annoncées
dans le plan o ne suffiront pas à
résoudre le problème du financement de
l'eau je crois que c'est assez
convergent en revanche nous saluons bien
évidemment et je vais passer je vais
passer la parole on peut pas selon
évidemment la volonté présidentielle de
déployer le recours à la réalisation des
eaux usées traités sert de passer de
moins de 1% à 10% c'était une
proposition que nous avions porté dans
notre Manifeste 2022 2027 qui
correspondait à notre proposition pour
pour les candidats au législatives et à
la présidentielle et qui s'accompagnait
d'une série de demandes de proposition
par exemple la simplification des
démarches administratives pour les
porteurs de projets les porteurs de
projets bien sûr les collectivités
locales la mise en place d'un guichet
unique pour faciliter les démarches des
porteurs de projets et éviter la
démultiplication des démarches
administratives et également parmi
d'autres propositions
l'allongement la durée de
l'expérimentation parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est sur une durée de 5 ans qui est
insuffisante pour déployer de manière
satisfaisante des projets de
réutilisation des objets traités et
également la création d'un observatoire
des
zones non conventionnels pour bénéficier
de retours d'expérience et qu'en fait il
y a des partages des partages
d'informations d'expérience entre les
collectivités locales qui déploraient
des solutions des solutions
européens qui ont quand même avancé
là-dessus par entre autres voilà les
spams et l'Italie c'est quoi les retours
parce qu'on a l'impression que le retour
d'expérience européen n'existe pas
bonjour bonjour tout le monde bonjour
pardon bonjour tout le monde merci
monsieur le rapporteur de nous recevoir
donc effectivement le retour
d'expérience ne se fait pas et
en fin de compte on communique peu en
fin de compte sur ce qu'on est capable
de faire ce qu'on fait déjà en France
parce que malgré tout même si c'est
important il y a quand même des
initiatives qui existent depuis très
longtemps plus de 15 ans et qui
aujourd'hui donne largement satisfaction
dans la question qui était posée c'est
est-ce que la ruth est une bonne idée je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la posture de tout
le monde c'est de dire oui c'est une
bonne idée bien évidemment maintenant
comme on l'a dit en introduction ce sera
pas le levier qui va résoudre tous les
problématiques en fin de compte si on
veut vraiment travailler le sujet de la
sobriété on doit avoir déjà une vision
un peu plus globale et territoriale
c'est indispensable et en fin de compte
la réalisation des eaux usées c'est une
brique parmi différentes solutions la
performance des réseaux la performance
des usines la réutilisation la sobriété
au niveau des agriculteurs au niveau des
usagers etc
et enfin cette Torah lui égard
effectivement à la problématique de
l'industrie de la mer et puis tout ce
que ça peut positionner donc c'est
vraiment une bride ça signifie quoi ça
signifie que par rapport au projet de
territoire de la gestion de l'eau
cette notion de territorialité elle est
fondamentale et effectivement la réunion
doit être
identifié comme étant cette brique et on
y associe en fin de compte tous les
sujets de biodiversité débit des sièges
etc et pourquoi c'est une bonne idée
parce que comme je l'ai dit même si on
en parle pas beaucoup en France même
s'il y a très peu de retours
d'expérience par rapport à ce qui se
fait en Italie en Espagne et on pourrait
aller au-delà parce que dans le monde je
veux dire vous avez Israël vous avez
Singapour vous avez même des pays
voilà mais parce que on est on est à
proximité mais en fin de compte
techniquement rien ne s'oppose c'est pas
compliqué à mettre en place un
dispositif et de l'engager ça demande un
peu de travail parce qu'il faut avoir
une vision territoriale
quels sont les usagers quel type d'eau
qualité quantité et comment ce qu'on
peut organiser ce dispositif et quelle
est la part là-bas les points qu'il faut
intégrer dedans c'est bon effectivement
c'est un traitement qui vit en plus du
reste donc ça veut dire des coûts
supplémentaires la question est pas de
se dire mais est-ce que ça coûte moins
cher que d'utiliser le potable pour
nettoyer les rues la question de se dire
mais si je ne fais rien qu'est-ce qui se
passe combien ça m'a coûté de mettre des
camions citerne d'emmener des palettes
d'eau pour alimenter des villages qui
cet été n'ont pas eu d'eau et en fin de
compte il y a une équation globale et
puis le bout du bout si on ne fait rien
qu'il y a plus d'eau combien l'ensemble
de ces dispositions au dispositions
qu'il faudra mettre en place coûteront
au regard de la mise en place de la
réutilisation des eaux usées donc
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait alors
vous palier en introduction de la
complexité je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y
a une certaine complexité pourquoi parce
que parce que réutiliser les eaux usées
on sait d'où elles viennent et il y a la
peur éventuellement que ça va générer
derrière un centre de problèmes
sanitaire etc aujourd'hui le dispositif
peut très bien cadré il y a des retours
d'expérience qui qui sont au-delà de je
dirais de de ceux qui existent depuis
une quinzaine d'années mais même les
derniers retours d'expérience qui date
de un an deux ans dans le cadre d'études
expérimentale montre qu'on est capable
de faire on peut probablement accélérer
réutilisation tout simplement de se
retourner l'expérience faisons
jurisprudence de ce qui a été fait des
dispositifs qui sont mis en place pour
contrôler s'assurer que tout va bien et
je pense qu'on peut ensuite accélérer la
mise en place des différents dossiers
donc oui la réussite c'est une bonne
idée elle doit s'inscrire dans un projet
de territoire en intègre les différents
Levieux qui les différents leviers qui
permettront de faire cette sobriété de
préserver la ressource mais ça s'intègre
dans un projet territorial qui va
au-delà probablement des délimitations
des collectivités puisque on va
embarquer du monde et là il y a un vrai
sujet
territorial mais on voit bien qu'il y a
quand même un parapluie qui est ouvert
au niveau national par rapport à
l'approche normative etc et celui-ci il
est quand même suffisamment plus
puissant alors l'approche territoriale
aucun souci on est complètement dans ces
sujets là donc je l'évacue assez
rapidement mais le principal froid
aujourd'hui et il est au niveau à la
fois des RS et du ministère de la santé
de toute façon la difficulté devant
laquelle aujourd'hui on se situe elle
est dans le temps
technico administratif pour valider un
projet et donc les garanties que l'on
est capable d'apporter national ça
relève du National ça relève du
département puisque les dossiers sont
soumis aux ARS au coder de ce
département je suis désolé mais il
s'appuie sur c'est pour ça que je dis un
chapeau normatif au niveau national il y
a un cadre
réglementé
sur le sujet parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on aborde le sujet on a beaucoup de
mal à identifier aujourd'hui la manière
dont la situation peut évoluer d'une
manière plus plus franche et plus
directe on a l'impression que on est
englué dans un marais et qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à effectivement à s'en
sortir sur ce sujet sur le plan national
déjà sur l'irrigation c'est possible et
c'est très peu utilisé
pourquoi c'est voilà c'est possible déjà
à l'heure actuelle donc il y a des
possibilités et puis on voit bien que au
niveau industriel etc alors là on est on
est dans des freins qui sont quand même
très très importants et j'ai pour ça que
j'ai le sentiment que c'est pas
uniquement une échelle des ARS c'est
aussi au dessus je pense si je peux me
permettre je pense qu'il y a l'échelle
territoriale quand même extrêmement
importante pourquoi parce que vous allez
mettre autour de la table des si je peux
permettre des personnes qui n'ont pas
l'habitude réellement de cohabiter en
matière des usages de l'eau puisque dans
une dans une organisation vous allez
devoir mettre autour de la table des
industriels qui entre guillemets peuvent
être amenés à vivre leur vie etc qui va
mettre autour de la table c'est c'est ça
c'est une bonne question
c'est le comité de bassin c'est au
travers des assises de l'eau que l'on
décide d'ouvrir un chantier partagé sur
la route au niveau territoriale c'est
quoi la voix
c'est une question importante parce que
aujourd'hui pour commencer vraiment
avancer factuellement faut regarder
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on met comme
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme proposition
comme méthode il y a une échelle à
définir il y a une il y a une colonne
vertébrale les qui doit avoir cette
légitimité pour effectivement faire ce
travail là aujourd'hui je pense que si
on regarde il peut être en fonction mais
est-ce que ça doit être légiférer
normalisé à ce qu'il est départemental
est-ce qu'il est plutôt sous des sous
bassins est-ce qu'il est plutôt sur des
sur des sur des bassins de vie et cette
dimension est-ce que les agences de
l'eau doit ouvrir à chaque niveau
puisque là on est sur une approche
bassin versant et territoriale
vous avez tous les acteurs là
au niveau d'une agence de l'eau oui on a
tous les acteurs tout à fait
bon
réfléchissez on va mais c'est un sujet
il faut parce que on a l'impression
quand on sur ces histoires là en tout
cas
je pense parce que ça fait partie c'est
on va dire c'est portails en fait c'est
le portails
peut-être juste pour compléter le propos
de Christophe on nous pose souvent la
question de l'impact réel de la
réutilisation des auviers traités vous
savez les reportages parlent des golf et
on a l'impression que c'est quelque
chose de très anecdotique on a formalisé
dans le cadre de notre manifeste une
donnée qui nous semble assez
intéressante c'est que 10% de
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées
c'est à peu près 500 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau et ça représente 15 à 20%
des besoins en eau de l'agriculture donc
c'est pour indiquer l'effet d'impact et
je vous rejoins sur le constat lié à
l'irrigation parce que aujourd'hui on
est capable avec la Réunion d'adapter
des qualités de route c'est-à-dire de
tout à fait capable d'adapter à des à
des plans de tomates une qualité d'eau
qui sera pas de nécessitera pas le même
niveau de traitement que pour une eau
qui va nettoyer des bus des gars
scolaires donc on est tout à fait
capable de le faire mais effectivement
il y a des il y a des freins il y a des
freins importants et on est en attente
de lever de ses freins
pour l'échange mais c'était pour pousser
un peu le le bouchon et regarder où ce
qu'on a un petit peu des pointures pour
pouvoir effectivement avancer sur sur le
sujet on a fait le tour par rapport aux
plans haut globalement sur les réactions
que vous souhaitiez
éventuellement relever sur peut-être
la sobriété
les consommations domestiques la
tarification différenciée qui est un
sujet plus facile à dire qu'à faire
qui doit vous préoccuper
oui tout à fait alors peut-être
Christophe tu veux peut-être commencer
sur la partie métrologie et contacteur
d'été et tu parleras des tarifs donc sur
la consommation domestique aujourd'hui
donc effectivement depuis un moment
donné maintenant on observe clairement
une baisse en tous les cas des ce qu'on
appelle les consommations unitaires donc
les foyers consomment de moins en moins
il y a des effets sociologiques mais il
y a aussi un petit peu pondérées
tout simplement parce que je pense que
sur ces 10 dernières années on a observé
quand même de façon assez significative
des baisses de 2 3% par an je pense que
c'est un effet aussi de modernisation
des des outils ménagers qui ont moins
consommateurs d'eau etc etc donc
aujourd'hui effectivement on arrive on
arrive effectivement à ce palier alors
aujourd'hui travailler sur la sobriété
il y a deux il y a l'approche purement
technique et puis approche pédagogique
ou un moment donné il faut embarquer
tout le monde et expliquer pourquoi
c'est important d'un point de vue
technologique aujourd'hui il faut avoir
en tête que la mise en place de ce qu'on
appelle les compteurs intelligents donc
la télé relève ou la radio relève ont
permis alors déjà il y a à peu près 80%
en tous les cas des consommateurs qui
sont aujourd'hui équipés de ce type de
dispositif
40%
s'il vous plaît télé radio c'est pas
alors pas les mêmes effets la télé alors
la télé relève et la radio relève sont
deux dispositifs différents la télé
relève l'information vient vous au bon
moment vous le souhaitez la radio relève
il faut aller vers le dispositif pour le
récupérer mais même si vous avez des
dispositifs de radio relève si je peux
me permettre aujourd'hui on travaille
avec on peut amener travailler avec des
partenaires comme la poste comme les
équipes qui s'occupent des ordures
ménagères tous ceux qui ont l'habitude
de passer régulièrement dans les rues et
ça nous permet de récupérer les
informations donc on peut augmenter la
fréquence de collecte des informations
issues de la radio relève donc même pour
des collectivités qui sont en
radio-rélève on peut imaginer augmenter
cette fréquence et donc pouvoir offrir à
l'ensemble des usagers l'accès à des
informations qui vont lui permettre de
maîtriser leur consommation et de
regarder exactement où est-ce qu'ils en
sont
oui mais cela dit vous êtes un des
opérateurs la fréquence des relèves est
prévue dans le contrat comme vous êtes
en délégation de service public donc une
augmentation aura des conséquences
financières sur non une augmentation
pour la radiologue des fréquences si ça
va être un juste équilibre c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui ici effectivement pour
une facturation on doit passer un salon
deux fois par mois si on identifie au
travers d'un partenariat qu'on est
capable de collecter de façon différente
vous aurez une équation simple qu'est-ce
que je vais pouvoir ne pas plus faire
demain versus ce que je vais faire en
plus aujourd'hui et puis on va s'assurer
que l'équilibre soit égal à zéro pour
qu'effectivement il y a un service qui
soit je dirais opéré et dans un plus
juste équilibre des coûts existants
depuis le départ du contrat donc c'était
c'est une et c'est une équation qu'il
faut qu'on équilibre avec les avec les
collectivités
mais en tous les cas ça permet pour ceux
qui ont déjà la radio relève de pouvoir
accéder à une fréquence d'information
qui lui permet de d'avoir cette vraie
gestion au quotidien à la semaine au
moins de leur consommation et c'est
clair que aujourd'hui les systèmes de
télérelève et où autres assimilés sont
je dirais sont une vraie aide pour
l'ensemble des citoyens à bien optimiser
leur consommation bien identifier la
huile consomme
identifier les éventuels fuites et
engager les actions correctives et ça
c'est un vrai je dirais c'est un vrai
plus mais là aussi j'aurais tendance à
dire que dans le cas d'une
démarche un peu plus globale un peu plus
territoriale je reprends cela monsieur
le rapporteur c'est une brique avec la
rue 8 avec les autres actions on est
d'accord après il y a toute la question
de l'accessibilité le fait que les gens
s'approprient aussi la démarche et ça
c'est un vrai sujet aussi en soi plus la
gestion des immeubles collectifs etc ou
là également c'est pas c'est pas simple
alors effectivement vous vous avez
raison on le voit bien aujourd'hui que
c'est un vrai travail de fond pour que
les gens effectivement régulièrement
s'approprient les outils alors on le
voit les premiers mois tout le monde
entre guillemets s'amusent et va voir et
puis après il y a une certaine lassitude
ou en tous les cas on oublie donc c'est
comment est-ce que les dispositifs
puissent admis pour régulièrement
relancer les je dirais les usagers sur
le fait que a on observe des
consommations normales donc c'est
l'ensemble du dispositif de services qui
peut être associé puisque en fin de
compte la télé vous avez une information
où vous allez avoir une information
régulière comment cette information
régulière peut être renvoyée vers les
usagers en disant tiens il se passe
quelque chose est-ce que vous pouvez
regarder etc donc c'est l'animation
qu'on peut créer autour de ça et ça
c'est extrêmement important et puis
après il y a je dirais les les
problématiques qui sont associées à
excusez moi monsieur le rapporteur la
deuxième le deuxième point c'était
parler des bâtiments collectif et puis
les bâtiments collectif vous avez
aujourd'hui un travail de fond qui est
fait effectivement avec les syndics et
autres pour mettre des sous-contages
pour que effectivement à un moment donné
il y a cette sensibilisation sur sur à
la fois le la consommation individuelle
mais aussi le fait qu'on puisse observer
ce qui se passe entre le compteur
général et chaque compteur individuel
puisque vous avez une zone qui est une
zone commune dans lequel on peut
observer régulièrement des dérives et
s'il n'y a pas de contrôle là est-ce que
vous pensez que de ce point de vue là il
faudra une obligation légale parce que
là dans certains cas
dans certains syndics ça ne fonctionne
pas quelqu'un plusieurs
si opposent et on ne peut pas avancer
sur le sujet donc ce que vous pensez
qu'une obligation légale sur les
compteurs individuels pour être
je dirais que je laisse au service de
l'État et à décider si on doit
transformer puisqu'on parle de la les
mains donc cette loi qui existe vers une
je dirais une une la possibilité de le
faire à une obligation légale il est
clair que si on considère que c'est un
levier pour sensibiliser encore plus de
monde l'action de sobriété peut-être que
c'est la une voix qu'il faudra utiliser
mais là je laisse je laisse je dirais
les compétences en présence se décider
peut-être que je peux rebondir juste
pour pour abonder dans votre sens
monsieur le rapporteur quand on
interroge les Français sur leur capacité
à agir ils ont envie d'agir c'est-à-dire
que on a une majorité de Français qui
nous disent qu'ils sont intéressés par
un service qui pourrait leur permettre
de suivre leur consommation d'eau donc
il y a une démarche il y a une démarche
d'adhésion mais il y a aussi une
démarche d'accompagnement à laquelle
participe nos entreprises c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui en fonction des demandes
des collectivités locales on est en
capacité de participer à ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un accompagnement à la
prévention pour pour que l'usager puisse
être pleinement informé des démarches
qui le conduisent peut-être à avoir un
comportement pas toujours très vertu en
matière de consommation d'eau potable il
existe des outils par exemple des
collaborations avec des plombiers
solidaires ou avec le
qui permet en fonction des besoins des
collectivités locales d'aller au devant
des des foyers pour leur expliquer de
temps en temps ça peut être utile
comment comment maîtriser comment
réguler leur consommation d'eau parce
que ça peut participer aussi d'une d'une
démarche d'accompagnement
par ailleurs on discutait en préparant
évidemment cette audition
nous voulons assister sur le fait que la
sobriété ne va pas porter uniquement sur
les usages particuliers même si il doit
y avoir une sensibilisation de
l'ensemble de la population ça nous
semble ça nous semble indispensable
parce qu'il faudrait pas qu'on aboutisse
j'allais dire à des excès c'est
pratiquement à durationnement on sait
par exemple que l'été en période de
canicule il vaut mieux qu'un seniorit
prenne une douche plutôt qui se prive du
d'une douche parce qu'il y a une
dimension sanitaire ça peut être la
température du corps donc ce que l'on ce
que l'on essaie de soit on essaie de
réfléchir ensemble de manière collective
c'est quand même la pérennité d'un
service
la qualification aussi des cellules de
crise par rapport à ça qui est
aujourd'hui bon parfois des réflexes on
va dire assez commun et pas suffisamment
différencier il y a pas de souci c'est
aussi par exemple le fait que quand on a
planté un arbre depuis trois ans si on
subit un arrêté sécheresse on élimine un
capital qui voilà donc il faut vraiment
faire un peu plus de dentelle qu'on en
fait aujourd'hui dans la dans la gestion
de crise ça ça semble être un sujet
effectivement
très très important sur les sur les
pratiques et sur les sobriétés on a vu
des plans à un moment donné type Maco
etc qui permettait d'intervenir avec des
fonds européens je crois sur des
politiques de sobriété
équipé avec des kits les ménages pour
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
consommation qui était moindre
tout ce qui va dans
le sens
des nouveaux matériels bien évidemment
mais pas que il suffit d'avoir un
robinet mousseur qui est
tout de suite 10% rien que en faisant
l'impact globalement du ballon d'eau
chaude sur
l'avenue douche le lave-linge et le
lave-vaisselle qui sont des gros postes
de consommation d'eau parieur déco poste
de consommation d'énergie parce que faut
chauffer l'eau donc oui bien sûr tout ce
qui va dans le sens de l'objectif de sob
mais c'est pas très organisé à l'heure
actuelle il y a des quelques démarches
volontaristes mais quand on y regarde un
peu plus près
il y a globalement enfin pour le coup on
va dire la stratégie pédagogique
d'accompagnement des
usagers pour aller vers une démarche
déjà de sobriété simplement au niveau de
l'utilisation et quand même pauvre quand
on regarde bien donc les entreprises de
l'eau on avait on a développé au mois de
juin dernier 2022 donc une campagne de
communication pour appeler nos
concitoyens
et l'appel de ministère de la transition
écologique c'est vrai qu'on était un
petit peu seul en la matière et je crois
que de toute façon ce sont des campagnes
qui vont devoir être
redéveloppés à l'avenir pas seulement si
on s'apprête à avoir un été sec on voit
bien qu'il faut aussi développer des
objectifs de sobriété en période
hivernale puisqu'on est aussi en
situation de tension par rapport à la
ressource en palette verbale donc il y a
probablement des des comportements à
faire évoluer avec encore une fois le
souci de ne culpabiliser de ne pas
culpabiliser les usagers et simplement
de garantir une information un petit peu
plus un petit peu plus large pour que
pour que les efforts soient partagés et
qui soient aussi compris à l'échelle du
territoire ça rejoint à votre question
sur la gestion de crise c'est-à-dire
qu'on sait que quand on fait 5 km et
qu'on va dans un département et qu'il y
a des usages de l'eau qui sont autorisés
alors qu'ils ne sont pas à côté c'est
très difficile à comprendre et ça fait
partie des annonces qui ont été faites
en marge du plan haut notamment en
prévision de l'été 2023 il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une lisibilité
des mesures qui sont prises de manière à
ce que chacun des usagers puisse entre
guillemets consentir sans avoir un
sentiment de d'injust
[Musique]
pendant que j'ai la parole j'en profite
j'ajoute ma petite pierre concernant la
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées en
fait parce qu'on est présent et très
présent aussi en Italie en Espagne donc
on a un retour d'expérience extrêmement
important puisque là-bas la
réutilisation des eaux usées épurées ça
fonctionne depuis au moins 20 ans très
large échelle donc les process sont
éprouvés ça marche et voilà c'est les
mêmes plus un sujet et non dans ces pays
là il est il est inconcevable par
exemple d'arroser un golf avec de l'eau
potable par exemple je ferme ma
parenthèse je reviens donc sur la sur la
qualité de l'eau c'était la question en
fait une de vos questions c'était la
protection des captages donc
effectivement faut commencer par le
l'aspect préventif
donc en fait je vais vous parler d'un
exemple très concret puisque l'afp2e a
noué un partenariat avec l'association
permanente des chambres d'agriculture en
fait qui permettait l'objectif c'était
de travailler sur 1000 captages
prioritaires en France donc ça c'est une
action qui a déjà été faite par le passé
et en fait la force de ce partenariat
c'est vraiment de réunir tous les
acteurs les collectivités locales au
premier chef les agences de l'eau on en
parlait tout à l'heure et sur chaque
ressource il y a souvent plus de 100
agriculteurs qui sont concernés et
qu'est-ce qui est fait dans le cadre de
ce partenariat en fait on va utiliser
par exemple un logiciel pour modéliser
les mouvements des composés azotés et
l'évolution dans la nappe dans une nappe
phréatique par exemple
très concrètement on dans ce cadre là on
fait la vérification du matériel
agricole pour éviter les fuites de
phytosanitaires et puis il y a une
démarche globale de maîtrise des
intrants et en fait ça marche j'ai en
tête un exemple concret où on a vu une
évolution positive de la qualité de
l'eau avec moins de en l'occurrence la
disparition de traces de phytosanitaire
donc ça c'est l'aspect préventif sur la
qualité de l'eau c'est la priorité bien
sûr il y a l'aspect curatif donc c'était
une de vos questions alors évidemment on
sait nos entreprises ça va adapter tous
les traitements à la cadité de l'eau à
éliminer
on peut éliminer 80 à 90% des
micropollants donc ça il y a des tout un
tas de techniques qui sont qui sont qui
sont connus et évidemment ça génère un
traitement supplémentaire évidemment
pour pour ce traitement supplémentaire
avec un impact direct pour le prix de
l'eau ce qu'on peut dire c'est que même
avec ces traitements plus poussés
l'eau du robinet reste quand même
nettement moins cher que l'eau du long
bouteille avec une empreinte carbone qui
est bien meilleure beaucoup plus faible
et bien meilleur pour l'eau du l'eau du
robinet voilà un peu les deux aspects du
préventif d'abord et du curatif et voilà
pour l'aspect qualité de l'eau en
général
oui on est d'accord avec un prix de
l'eau en France qui est quand même un
peu inférieur à la moyenne européenne du
coup qui peut laisser des marges de
manœuvre aujourd'hui à ce niveau là mais
après dès qu'on fait une augmentation il
y a toujours des réactions mais on est
bien d'accord mais elles sont plutôt du
côté un peu moins au niveau des usagers
que des industriels et surtout des de la
filière agricole qui est la plus
sensible aujourd'hui mais bon sur les
points de Cannes sur les points de
captage à ce niveau là
je t'en prie peut-être sur la protection
des captages vous évoquez le travail qui
est fait sur les 1000 captages
prioritaires finalement il est quand
même relativement lourd en fait c'est
tout un travail le suivi des captages
prioritaires j'ai participé c'est quand
même assez long certains acteurs de la
filière proposent finalement d'aller
vers une limitation voire une
interdiction des intrants
phytosanitaires et autres dans
les périmètres le périmètre sensible des
captages à échéance de 10 ans comment
est-ce que voilà qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
qu'elles peuvent être les limites et
surtout quand même quels sont les
avantages je pense que pour vous ça
recèle beaucoup d'avantages
en tout cas je tout à l'heure c'est
l'objectif c'est bien de maîtriser les
intrants donc dans le périmètre immédiat
rapproché éloigné c'est bien c'est bien
la question
[Musique]
globalement ces 3% de la SAV à l'heure
actuelle
donc il y a des zones de conflits mais
en même temps quand on rapporte ça la
surface agricole utilisée c'est
relativement peu donc on pourrait se
permettre de tout protéger aujourd'hui
il faut voir comment on peut accompagner
mais ça devrait être un objectif assez
majeur compte tenu malgré tout des coûts
induits après pour traiter les
pollutions qui sont quand même
relativement élevées donc
juste ce qu'on peut ajouter c'est qu'en
fait le ce partenariat il est
relativement récent enfin il y a 15 ans
ça n'existait pas forcément avec des
acteurs qui se connaissaient assez peu
finalement et moi je crois beaucoup à
l'efficacité que les gens partagent les
enjeux que les agriculteurs partagent
leurs enjeux que les opérateurs de l'eau
et les collectivités locales et en fait
c'est en enrichissant comme ça de
manière commune que on avancera puisque
c'est quand même assez consensuel et
justement on arrive à des résultats
probants tout à fait
la question qui était aussi abordée
précédemment sur comment on accompagne
malgré tout l'évolution des pratiques au
niveau des services rendus bon voilà il
faut aussi organiser sans doute
l'accompagnement aussi la rétentation de
la filière par rapport à ça c'est là où
les agences de l'eau peuvent jouer un
rôle d'accompagnement
qui peut être effectivement
pertinent et intéressant
sachant que aujourd'hui dans dans nos
métiers on a déjà vis-à-vis d'un bon
nombre de
d'exploitants agricole des relations
puisque notre métier nous amène à
produire des bouts et ses bouts font
l'objet de plan des pandage donc ça veut
dire qu'on a déjà une relation avec les
champs d'agriculture pour aider au plan
d'épandage pour accompagner dans
l'analyse des sols identification des
besoins ou pas donc cette relation elle
existe et on est déjà dans une logique
un peu entre guillemets de conseil
puisque on oriente les besoins je dirais
indépandage en fonction de du sol donc
cette relation existe comment ce qu'on
l'a fait monter d'un cran pour
effectivement qu'elle touche cette
fois-ci je dirais la notion d'usage des
autres produits comment est-ce qu'on
peut aider les les agriculteurs à
substituer des engrais chimiques à des
engrais verts et puis là on peut se
poser plein de questions sur ce qui
existe aujourd'hui en matière de gestion
des bouts traitement des bouts et
comment est-ce qu'on est capable à
partir des bouts et de différentes
dispositifs de fabriquer des engrais
verts donc on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
la profession à la capacité en tous les
cas d'avoir je dirais une marche
supplémentaire de progrès et je dirais
d'accompagnement des exploitants et des
agriculteurs dans leur dans leur propre
démarche donc on est concerné par l'eau
on est concerné par les bouts et puis et
demain on peut être concernés aussi du
compote du compostage qui aujourd'hui
est normalisé nefu 44,95 c'est un
produit ce n'est plus un déchet et et
les agriculteurs donc on apporte de
l'amendement organique etc donc on a
déjà ces démarches maintenant ce qu'il
faut c'est effectivement monter d'un
cran mais ça ne peut se faire qu'à
partir du moment où il y a je dirais
aussi un cadre qui donne je dirais une
légitimité pour pouvoir avancer de cette
façon là et puis après il y a ce qu'on
va faire immédiatement et puis pour la
prévention et puis comment est-ce que je
gère ce qui est déjà dans le sol et on
l'a vu encore récemment ou 10 ans après
l'interdiction d'un produit on a tous
les métabolites qui apparaissent et
qu'il va falloir qu'il va falloir
traiter bien sûr
sur le cadre
il a aussi il y a des il y a des voix
qui peut éventuellement peuvent être
travaillées puisque au-delà d'une
approche territoriale et d'une gestion à
l'échelle des bassins versants et des
sous bassins se pose la question de
comment on pilote et on accompagne au
mieux les filières professionnels dans
des stratégies effectivement qui peuvent
être partagées et du coup on interroge
aujourd'hui le positionnement des
collectivités par rapport à ça
et ça re questionne peut-être la
position des régions d'une part sur le
fait que les régions ont la compétence
économique et donc l'accompagnement
aussi au niveau des filières et qu'on
elles peuvent être sur certains sujets à
la croisée des chemins au travers du
stradette mais sur des enjeux aussi
d'évolution territoriale
et des espaces aussi Naturels Sensibles
donc
filière professionnelle se croisent au
niveau régional si on fait court donc
des stratégies partagées pourraient
éventuellement se retrouver alors c'est
pas il y a des gestions différenciées au
niveau des régions
je vais parler pour la mienne sur la
nouvelle Aquitaine pour le coup il y a
un travail de fond qui a été fait sur un
climatera etc mais on pourrait imaginer
demain que des traceségies communes de
croisement entre filières agricoles même
votre propre filière au niveau régional
pour voir comment des compétences
peuvent se retrouver sur des
accompagnements sur le terrain ça peut
ça pourrait vous voyez là dessus
qui me permet de la révision de la
directive aux résidus urbaines qui vise
à renforcer la dimension de station
d'épuration ressources et à développer
jusqu'à notre a été énergétique à
l'échelle à
l'échelle et à une
gisement à la fois de compétences de
matière grise et de
progression partenariale pour rejoindre
les objectifs que vous décrez
parce que vous posez la question du
cadre c'est sûr parce que même au niveau
des chambres d'agrives on va bien sûr ça
crée un point d'entrée mais même là il
faut en même temps sédimenter sur les
territoires regarder un peu comment ça
se passe c'est une question très bien
c'est intéressant
le volet sobriété sur sur la question de
des réseaux parce que c'est un sujet
qu'on a beaucoup entendu parler ces
dernières semaines sur lesquelles on a
évidemment
beaucoup de beaucoup de retours
d'expérience à apporter peut-être
Vincent oui alors directement on va
commencer par les chiffres en fait
quelques indicateurs pour mesurer la
performance des réseaux aujourd'hui de
80,4% en moyenne le rendement de réseau
avec des disparités très fortes
géographiques selon et selon qu'on est
en rural ou en urbain si on se compare
par rapport aux autres pays donc on est
à 79% au Royaume-Uni 73% en Belgique et
62% en Italie donc on est on est pas
trop mal placé en France ceci dit il
faut faire mieux il faut atteindre 85 et
90% en plus donc ça c'est chaque
pourcentage gagné dans ce cas de figure
et
et c'est la règle
au-delà de 90 95%, il faut un rapport
coût bénéfice qui qui on peut se dire un
moment on dit stop ça ne vaut plus la
peine
il est il est il est bien
identifié en fait à chaque territoire
c'est à dire il faut raisonner si on est
en rural si on est en
urbain c'est un peu différent
effectivement
ça c'est un premier indicateur et puis
donc c'était une de vos questions le
deuxième indicateur c'est le taux de
renouvellement enfin le taux
d'investissement qui est en moyenne en
France de 0,67% par an donc c'est
insuffisant puisque ça veut dire un taux
de renouvellement tous les 150 ans
donc ça veut dire en espèce qu'on
renouvelle 0,67% du linéaire en moyenne
nous ce que nous proposons nous estimons
qu'il faudrait atteindre 1,5% par an
donc ce qui veut dire quand même un peu
plus que doubler ces investissements
donc c'est pas neutre c'est très
significatif donc ça c'est un point un
point extrêmement important et puis je
vais le coupler on en a parlé tout à
l'heure des compteurs intelligents en
fait il faut pas oublier l'objectif
c'est de diminuer la pression sur la
ressource diminuer les fuites mais le
renouvellement des réseaux ce n'est
qu'une brique il faut le coupler c'est
notre conviction notamment sur là où il
y a des stress hydriques avec des
compteurs intelligents c'est à dire
comme ça ça permettra de calculer des
rendements de réseau de manière
quotidienne notamment quand on a du
télévé vous savez qu'aujourd'hui le
rendement de réseau on le calcule une
fois par an là on peut passer c'est
pertinent de le calculer une fois par
semaine qu'on a du télé relevé donc on
passe à une fréquence de contrôle qui
est multipliée par 52 donc une faculté
d'agir d'aller chercher les fuites qui
est qui est totalement démultipliée
donc enfin notre on a encore une fois
notre conviction là où il y a du stress
hydrique là où il y a des pressions sur
la ressource
le couplage
digitalisation avec renouvellement nous
semble particulièrement pertinente
s'il vous plaît ce que vous avez la part
du télé relevé alors évidemment dans les
territoires urbains métropolitain
j'imagine que c'est très élevé mais dans
les territoires plus ruraux
on a passé de donner on ne parlait tout
à l'heure de 40% mais la part de stricte
liée au téléréalité on pourra vous la
donner oui mais c'est bien sûr
intéressant
parce que ça montre bien que si par
contre c'est globalement à peu près
réparti c'est autre chose mais c'est un
sujet tu as raison c'est un sujet qui
est intéressant
de toute façon plus on pourra développer
la qualité de du contrôle et la qualité
des remontées d'information plus on
pourra dans la finesse d'analyse mais
c'est valable pour le macro comme pour
le micro c'est que là pour le coup c'est
le grand cycle et le petit cycle se
réunit à tous les niveaux et donc ça ça
fera l'objet dans le rapport sans doute
d'une préconisation aussi d'une approche
particulière sur l'amélioration d'une
manière générale du système
d'information et de gestion à tous les
niveaux si je peux pas mettre d'ailleurs
un complément monsieur le rapporteur si
je vais beaucoup plus loin que ce que
disait Vincent c'est que et je m'appuie
sur le rapport interministériel qui
était publié sur ce qui s'est passé en
2000 l'été 2022 si je rajoute à cette
dimension là pour rejoindre cette
approche territoriale la façon dont on
est capable de mesurer comment les
captages les forages
ou pas en capacité au corps à produire
donc vous rajoutez les captages vous
rajoutez les compteurs de sectorisation
vous rajoutez la télé relève on a une
vision et une équation qui dans le cas
de la réorganisation liée à l'autre peut
permettre à une collectivité avoir une
gestion dynamique de sa ressource et se
dire voilà comment je vais faire peut
l'aider à programmer les interconnexions
etc et donc on voit bien que la data
donc la digitte alors la donnée devient
essentielle effectivement je me sens que
un centre de préfet disait mais en fin
de compte on a traîné pour des arrêter
parce qu'on manquait d'informations et
donc on voit bien que l'équipement
probablement l'équipement de ses forages
la capacité à avoir une donnée temps
réel couper un ensemble de ça permet une
gestion dynamique et une bonne un bon
équilibre dans l'utilisation des
différentes ressources qu’un territoire
peut posséder on en est convaincu à de
ça donc je pense qu'on a pu voir
fortement là dessus c'est le fait de
partager de manière très fine les enjeux
à partir du moment maîtrise mieux
véritablement la ressource qui est
disponible mais après il faut bien se la
partager il faut bien discuter il faut
bien négocier de toute manière
j'ajoute une révolution pour nous dans
notre métier c'est vous parliez de micro
quand on a du télévé là j'ai un exemple
très concret tous les jours on détecte
les gens qui ont une fuite c'est
vraiment on apporte un service qui est
carrément amélioré et une relation
client qui est ça change tout pour notre
métier c'est c'est vraiment on est passé
dans le futur et ça nous semble
particulièrement intéressant
et le dernier point si je fais me
permettre c'est le fait d'avoir cette
information en amont c'est comment je
peux non pas éviter la crise mais
préparer la crise si au mois de janvier
je suis capable de dire que en fonction
de la lisibilité que j'ai sur les 15 20
ans de d'information concernant mes
ressources je suis capable de dire
attention je suis dans une valeur
extrêmement basse on est au mois de
janvier statistiquement la possibilité
pour qu'elle revienne un niveau normal
extrêmement faible ça veut dire déjà
dans l'anticipation ça veut dire que on
est moins dans la précipitation quand il
va falloir engager les arrêtés
sensibiliser les uns les autres et le
jour où la crise arrive on est préparé
et on a peut-être déjà mis en place des
dispositifs qui évite vraiment l'action
et la réaction
oui oui tout à fait peut-être un message
général pour conclure qui je pense
certainement assez commun avec
l'ensemble des personnes que vous avez
auditionnées des experts que vous avez
entendu notre conviction c'est que
aujourd'hui les usages de l'eau doivent
faire l'objet d'abord d'une d'une
information d'une communication assez
large en transparence avec avec le
public c'était jusqu'ici un enjeu qui
était quand même assez méconnu y compris
des élus parfois donc il y a aussi
aujourd'hui un une volonté de comprendre
une volonté de comprendre aussi en quoi
consiste la facture d'eau concrètement
quels sont les services qui sont
derrière quelle est la performance qu'il
y a derrière ce que ça veut dire une
performance des services publics de
d'assainissement qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière donc toute clarification qui
passe bien sûr par exemple la réforme
des redevances mais de manière générale
toute vérification qui participe d'une
prise de conscience globale de ce que
signifie aujourd'hui un service public
d'assainissement performant sur chaque
territoire parce que c'est bien une
compétence territoriale de sur le
territoire métropolitain et ultramarins
parce qu'on en a pas parlé mais il y a
de très très gros enjeux en outre-mer
globalement doit mobiliser l'ensemble
des acteurs j'allais dire on est tous
dans le même bateau pardonnez-moi pour
cette image qui est un peu un peu
trivial mais opérateur public opérateur
privé autorité administrative pouvoir
public collectivités locales je crois
qu'on est on est tous mobilisés vers un
même enjeu qui est la préservation de la
ressource la préservation d'un service
public d'audassaiblissement qui soit de
qualité qui soit à la hauteur des
standards qu'on souhaite qu'on souhaite
porter en rappelant aussi qu'il y a une
partie de la population française qu'il
n'y a pas forcément accès et de ce point
de vue la tarification sociale a du sens
je rappelle qu'on a été les premiers
nous les entreprises de l'eau à déployer
des shako à proposer des chapeaux aux
collectivités locales ça fait aussi
partie des pistes qu'il faut
probablement renforcer de manière à ce
que tous nos concitoyens puissent avoir
un accès équitable assez services d'eau
d'assainissement et de manière aussi
être vigilant je pense particulièrement
aux impayés puisque depuis la loi brute
on constate qu'il y a une montée en
flèche des impayées oui voilà
alors oui nous dans le cas du Manifeste
on a fait effectivement on a fait un
constat des propositions là dessus alors
c'est un constat partagé avec la SNCF ce
qu'on a discuté sur une autre table
ronde il y a effectivement une montée en
puissance des impayés ce que nous on
recommande c'est pouvoir doter les mers
de la capacité à collecter les impayés
du côté des foyers qui n'ont pas de
difficultés financières avec l'idée que
là il y a des sommes à aller chercher de
manière à pouvoir par ailleurs
accompagner les familles qui sont les
plus précaires des fois il y a les plus
précaires pour avoir une véritable
politique sociale de l'eau aujourd'hui
les mères n'ont pas la capacité ils ne
peuvent pas aller collecter ces sommes
achetez bien dans les foyers qui n'ont
pas de difficultés financières donc il
nous semble qu'il y a un peu de poids de
mesure on peut pas à la fois mettre en
place des services publics de
d'assainissement qui requiert des
investissements renforcés pour lesquels
il va falloir que les collectivités
locales investissent et à côté avoir des
impayés dans des foyers qui sont en
capacité de payer ses factures d'eau
alors oui je pense qu'on pourra dans le
manifeste on a fait un travail de
formalisation de ce sujet si vous voulez
on va vous faire passer c'est une
conviction forte
croisement des données même à l'échelle
de la mer
c'est pour ça que je regardais mais vous
avez raison de poser le sujet sur la
table et les pertinent après il y a
aussi la comment on paye quels sont les
moyens de paiement c'est toujours
intéressant de regarder un peu
aussi les moyens de paiement qui sont
les plus efficaces aussi par rapport à
ça c'est aussi un sujet
n'oubliez pas qu'au niveau de
l'information de la communication ça n'a
rien de péjoratif dans ce que je vais te
dire mais niveau français des moyens des
moyens des Français pardon c'est un
niveau 3e
on l'oublie souvent aussi dans les
éléments et les éléments de langage
comment on communique
on peut dire que l'eau l'assainissement
on l'entend était un sujet d'expert dans
lesquels finalement les acteurs se
parlaient entre eux dans un système un
petit peu de n'existe pas encore
d'évaluation comparatives comparative
véritablement diffuser et communiquer
mais à l'échelle des collectivités
locales ça peut exister mais quand on
regarde bien les tableaux sont pas
suffisamment normés et sont pas
suffisamment communiqués de manière
générale pour savoir comment une
collectivité se situe son prix en mètre
cube comparé au d'autres etc à tous les
niveaux et on peut rêver demain d'avoir
une une fiche ressource par foyer qui
synthétise en fait tous les éléments de
ressources qu'un foyer consomme c'est
pas exclusivement de l'eau parce que
c'est un sujet qui est commun en fait
entre l'énergie l'électricité l'eau etc
le but du jeu c'est de dire comment moi
dans un foyer quelle est la vision de
mes ressources dénommées consommation
qui donne du sens d'une autre manière on
parle pas que d'eau on parle aussi
d'énergie
et ça prend plus de profondeur
ce que signifie la potabilisation
c'est encore un peu difficile
les collectivités qui gèrent l'eau sont
des opérateurs de l'eau et sont pas
forcément des spécialistes de la
communication alors même si en général
les délégataires proposent une
communication par an ça se traduit pas
forcément concrètement je pense qu'il
faudrait aussi que vous accompagniez les
collectivités dans cette communication
ça me semble assez important je vous rej
tout à fait alors en général on s'adapte
un petit peu aux demandes des
collectivités parce que il y en a aussi
qui souhaitent communiquer sur les
sujets de d'assainissement de leur côté
mais je vous rejoins complètement sur
l'objectif de communication un petit peu
un petit peu plus large encore une fois
la compréhension de la des niveaux de
qualité d'eau potable qui sont proposés
aujourd'hui en France la confiance dans
l'eau potable elle repose aussi sur la
bonne connaissance qu'on peut en avoir
et par ailleurs je crois que vous avez
vu passer le rapport de l'igodd sur sur
les eaux résiduelles la semaine dernière
on constate aussi que l'assainissement
c'est une sorte de trou noir c'est à
dire que personne ne sait vraiment ce
qui s'y passe personne ne sait
exactement quels sont les enjeux on en a
un petit peu parlé pendant la crise
covid quand même parce que c'était un
élément un indicateur pour pour le suivi
épidémiologique mais ça reste un sujet
qui est encore assez flou Christophe
Tanguy parlait de la dimension
ressources des stations d'épurations qui
demain va permettre à la fois de
développer des ressources
supplémentaires pour les agriculteurs et
aussi pour les collectivités locales
dans un contexte de tension financière
je pense que c'est ce sont des pistes
qui sont très intéressantes et sur
lesquelles on va devoir nous aussi
apprendre
à communiquer parce qu'aujourd'hui je
crois qu'une station d'épuration il y a
pas beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui
savent exactement ce que c'est et je
pense qu'on peut aussi développer la
pédagogie autour de ces outils qui sont
des beaux outils industriels qui sont
des outils déployés par des acteurs
économiques français qui mobilisent on a
dit de notre côté 28 000 collaborateurs
et on peut inclure bien sûr les équipes
des régimes on ça représente aussi un
savoir-faire français un savoir-faire
qui est non délocalisable qui a une
traduction en termes d'emploi et de
développement en territorial donc je
crois que ça mérite d'être effectivement
porté
chose à dire parce que la communication
institutionnelle est de plus en plus
observé avec distance de la part
malheureusement des
usagers des concitoyens donc c'est
vraiment un débat de fond si autour de
comment quels sont les meilleures axes
les meilleurs moyens les meilleurs
méthodes pour pouvoir toucher et
communiquer en tant que tel bon c'est un
vaste sujet en tout cas merci beaucoup
pour pour cet échange qui était vraiment
intéressant vous souhaite une excellente
réunion du CNF voilà vous transmettrez
nos amitiés à Monsieur Jean Launay vous
êtes sur notre retrouvé j'imagine
très bien très bonne
merci